Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have a
peek into DeepMind’s journey
into creating an AI that behaves like a human.
How? Well, by dropping it into a virtual
playhouse, asking humans to give it tasks,
judging it rather harshly, and hoping
that it learns something from it.
But, not so fast! First, we have to start
with an AI agent, a little assistant,
that already knows a few things. Just dropping
a randomly acting agent into this game would
do no good. So, how do we do that? Well,
scientists at DeepMind say that first,
we should ask it to look at humans interacting
with previous AI agents. And have it copy them.
Let’s call this behavioral cloning.
So, how good is behavioral cloning?
Well, the answer is not good at all. Let’s have
a look together. This agent has looked at humans
building towers from books, and now, it’s your
turn, little AI. And it does… not too well,
I am afraid. Oh my. That is not good.
Look. It has learned a bit from humans,
it is trying so hard, but unfortunately
it has no idea about how physics works,
and does not have the finesse
required to build this tower.
So, is that it? We can’t even write an AI that
clones what humans can already perform in virtual
worlds? Well, do not despair, because here comes
the second best part of the paper. In this work,
this agent is used just as a starting point,
and now, we can ask it to do a bunch of tasks,
and have humans give it a score. For
instance, here you see it trying to
arrange these fruits in a row. And, whenever
it progresses with this task, it gets a nice
spike in the score. And whenever it does not do
well, we can tell it that this is not the way.
Alright, but what does this process do for us?
Well, it creates an agent that can learn not
the behavior of humans, but the reward model
itself. What does that mean? Well, it tries to
learn what the human teacher would think about
what it is doing right now. And, is that useful?
Well, have a look at it yourself. Here is the
agent after it started to learn the reward model,
and, let’s build that tower again. First
try is not too bad, but the second one,
now look at that. That is a proper tower of
books right there. Very proud of you, little AI!
So, how well did it do? Here is the score
for a human player. Here it is for the
not too great first try with the behavioral
cloning AI. And now, hold on to your papers,
and look at that! This is the new agent. It does
almost as well as a real human does. Wow. This is
an amazing chart that shows that these agents
can learn tasks that require walking around,
understanding a bit of physics, and
a bit of finesse as well. I love it.
And, it can learn not just building towers, but
it also learned to build triangles of objects,
and of course, everyone’s favorite. What
good would an AI be if we could not teach
it to clean our room? So, can it do that?
Oh yes, and with flying colors. Loving it.
But wait, I said that this was the second
best part of the paper. What is the best part?
It is this. Remember, first, we start out from
the behavioral cloning agent, and start learning
the reward model. This does nearly as well as
a human does, so that is absolutely amazing,
we can teach an AI to behave like a human does in
these tasks. This is incredible. But that’s not
it. Get this, if we repeat this process and
let it learn for a bit longer, we get this.
Whoa! Are you seeing what I am seeing? Yes, that
is right, if we let it train for a bit longer,
this happens. It can even surpass humans at
building that tower. An AI that learns from
humans, and over time, even surpasses humans.
And, wait, it gets better, it surpasses humans
not just on this one particular task, but on
a set of over a 150 standardized tasks. Here
they are. Generally, it greatly outperforms in
instruction following-type tasks, while it is
a bit worse than humans at answering questions,
but it still does really well. Wow. Perhaps this
is one more step towards general intelligence.
And also, welcome to Two Minute Papers, Land
of the Fellow Scholars who look at bar charts and
make happy noises. Yeah! What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!